- We've talked a lot about cells in general,
but what I thought I would do in this video
is focus on plant cells, and in particular
focus on the cell walls of plant cells.
So this right over here, this is a
drawing of a plant cell.
And the thing that might jump out
at you immediately is instead of
drawing it as just kind of a roundish shape
like that, the way I've drawn a lot of
other cells, I've drawn this as kind of
a cubic structure, or a rectangular prism,
and that's because plant cells
can have a structure like that.
And so the next question is, well,
what gives them that shape?
What allows them to form that, kind of,
cubic rectangular prism shape?
And the answer is, it's the cell wall.
So this is the cell wall.
So let's make sure we can orient
ourselves properly in this picture.
So clearly, if I didn't have this cut-out,
all I would be seeing is the outside.
All I would be seeing is the cell wall.
But we've cut it out, and we can see
the different layers.
We have the cell wall on the outside.
Right below that, right below that
we have the cellular membrane,
or the plasma membrane.
So that's the cellular membrane.
Cellular membrane, right under that.
And then under that, the cellular membrane
is containing the cytoplasm.
And inside of the cytoplasm
we have all sorts of things.
This big thing that is taking up
a lot of the volume inside of this plant cell,
that's a vacuole, which we have described
in other videos.
Vacuole.
It's the combination of this
internal pressure, things like the vacuole
and, just frankly, the pressure
from all of the fluid inside the cell
pushing outwards, plus the cell wall
kind of holding it all in.
That's what gives plants their structure.
That's why a plant is able to grow,
and be upright.
A plant is able to grow and be upright.
So that's my drawing of a plant.
I actually have a plant in my room
that I'm looking at right now,
and it's able to grow and be upright.
And so you have the cell wall,
you have the cellular membrane,
you have the other organelles,
I have some chloroplasts here,
key for photosynthesis, our good friends
mitochondria.
We have our nuclear membrane,
or I should say this yellow thing
is the inner nuclear membrane.
It has the DNA inside.
Then you have the endoplasmic reticulum,
kind of containing that.
The rough ER, containing the ribosomes
or having the ribosomes on the membrane.
The smooth ER, not having the ribosomes.
Golgi apparatus, so that's a little bit
of a review.
But our focus here is on the cell wall.
So let's go back to that.
So if we zoom in on this, if we zoom in
on the cell wall right over here, we can
look at this diagram.
And over here, it might be a little bit
surprising to you.
Because when I've always imagined
a wall, a cell wall, I imagine something
like a brick wall.
Something that's impenetrable.
But this drawing shows us
something different.
And just to be clear what's going on here,
so this is our cellular membrane --
sorry I wrote cellular membrane,
so right over here I have my
lipid bi-layer.
And then right on top of that,
I have the cell wall.
But you see, it isn't just a thick,
like a brick wall, like something
that is impenetrable.
You see you have all these polysaccharide
fibers running across it.
So you have things like cellulose,
which we saw as a polymer of glucose,
arranged in a certain way.
Hemi-cellulose, which has different types
of monomers associated with it.
We have pectin, which is another
polysaccharaide.
And all of these things -- you've actually
probably eaten, if not today probably in the
last week, when we talk about fiber
in your diet, you're talking about things
like the cellulose and the pectin.
Things that your body can't digest.
When you eat a plant you're getting it,
because you're eating their cell walls.
And it does cool things, like
slows the absorption of glucose in your
intestines.
It absorbs water, so I guess you could say
things pass a little bit easier.
But the key thing here is this isn't
a wall.
This actually allows --
Or, it is a wall,
It's officially the cell wall.
But it's not a thick, impenetrable wall
like you might associate the wall
of the room that you're in.
You can see that it has space
for small molecules to flow.
And it's really more like a mesh,
or like a fabric.
And so the cellular membrane
actually has access to the fluid,
and to the molecules, that are
between the cells.
And so just to be clear what we're
looking at.
This layer right here, this cellular membrane,
that's the lipid bi-layer.
This right over here, this is the
cell wall.
I'll do that in a different color.
That is the cell wall.
And then right above the cell wall,
that's the space between the cells,
which we cell the middle lamella.
So the space between the cells
we call the middle lamella.
So this also is, right over here, is also
the middle lamella.
So all of that is interesting, but you might say,
"Okay, well, how hard is a cell?
I get that it's a mesh, but clearly the cells,
the plants are able to stand upright.
Is that because the cell wall provides
all of that rigidity?"
And the answer is, kind of.
The cell wall is like this mesh.
It helps the cells have their shape.
But if you stop watering a plant,
you're going to see it kind of
wilt over.
And that's because part of its ability
to stand up is from the internal pressure
of the cells.
But also part of its shape is the actual
cell wall.
Now, some of you might be saying,
"Well I've seen plants that are much,
much more rigid than this plant
that you've just drawn.
What about things like trees?
What about wood?
Wood seems very rigid.
In fact, so rigid that we can build
actual walls out of wood."
And the answer there is these
more mature plants, actually once the cell
has stopped growing and you have your
cell wall, more layers of cellulose and
other molecules can be built to form
what's called a secondary cell wall.
So this could be viewed as a primary
cell wall.
And then a thicker, secondary cell wall
could be built, which gives much,
much more rigidity.
And so when you look at wood,
what gives wood its structure,
even if you were to take out all of the
water, even if you were to dehydrate
the wood, it's still going to have
its rigidity, because the cellulose layers
and the other molecules that are
so thick that it's able to have its
rigid form.
Now that last thing I want to talk about.
We've already seen that the
cellular membrane has access to
the molecules floating around between
cells, but there's actually also
direct tunnels between adjacent plant cells.
And those direct tunnels I've drawn here
on this, outside of the cell walls
these little yellow circles, these are
plasmodesmata.
These are plasmodesmata.
To get a better understanding of what
they're like, imagine this is one cell.
So I'm writing here Cell 1.
And let's say this is Cell 2.
Cell 2 right over here.
And I have a cross-section.
You see the plasmodesmata are these
tunnels that form between not just the
membrane of the cell wall and the
plasmodesmata.
It forms between the two cells.
And so you can actually have a
flow of cytosol and small molecules
directly between these two cells.
And if you want to get a little bit more
involved in the structure, you have this
kind of smooth endoplasmic reticulum pipe
going through it.
But I want to make it very clear.
'Cause a lot of times when you
study biology it's all explained,
it seems all neat and clean and textbook.
But people are still studying exactly
why do we have these things?
What are they necessary?
What gets transported across these things,
and how are they able to transport,
and under what conditions are they?
So all of these areas, when you were to
kind of dig one layer deeper
than frankly I'm talking about,
you're getting into an area of
active research.
So anyway, hopefully this whole thing
gives you a little bit more appreciation
for the wood around you, the
plants, the house plants around you,
and even the salad that you might have
for lunch.